okay now this last one actually is not a
rational function so that's slightly
sneaky but it has another base that's
not a you can see that 8 minus 2 to the
X e missed that's why I want to pay some
close attention to how this question
works now unlike the previous one
no graph is provided to us so we need to
do a little bit of legwork to know
what's going on in the situation
visually and then we can actually
evaluate the answer they were looking
for
so the question very helpfully scaffolds
for us is sort of gives us a nudge in
the right direction it says find the
intercepts of this curve and then hence
a bunch of other stuff right so let's
just do one thing at a time let's find
the intercepts to find X intercepts what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to let y equal
0 so in this case that means 8 minus 2
DX equals 0 I can add 2 to the X to both
sides so to the power of something
equals 8 this is actually a nice whole
number value so hopefully you're seeing
along with me that that's x equals 3 2
cubed does give you 8 so that right
there that guy is our x-intercept check
1 I'm now going to work out my
y-intercept and I do that by switching
it around letting X equal 0 so Y is
going to be 8 minus 2 to the 0 there's
my substitution to the 0 is 1 so Y is
going to be equal to 7 so there's my
value right there now you can see it
then says I'm ready now to read the rest
of the question
hence find the area of the region
bounded by this curve and the corner
axis so let's do a rough sketch of this
ok what's it going to look like
well for starters because I've got these
are these two pieces of information here
and x-intercept and a y-intercept I'm
gonna put them on first okay so I'm
gonna put an x intercept of 3 let's put
that 3 there and then a y-intercept of 7
it doesn't matter that my scales are not
consistent with each other this picture
just needs to be good enough that I can
actually draw over the top of it now how
do I thread the needle of this well it's
an exponential function remember 2 to
the X so usually I have this kind of
shape in my head exponential growth but
of course this particular function has a
this sign in front of it exponential
term you've got minus to the X so
instead of a shape like of this you're
actually going to get something that's
upside down it's gonna look like that
and thankfully this shape right here
does actually match what we're trying to
fit into right so therefore what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna try and thread the
needle with this shape it's gonna look
something like that it's not my best
work but I don't need it to be beautiful
I just need to be good enough to work
out the relevant area it's the one
that's bounded by this curve and the
corner axis so therefore let's pick a
color and the size it's looking like
it's gonna be in here right this is
actually the spot where I am interested
in finding the area so I'm gonna say
area equals I need a lower bound enough
about now
there's a bit of a arm there's been a
red herring here right because in fact
that y-intercept that we found it helps
us work out what the graph looks like
but it we don't need it to actually work
out the area all I need is the
x-intercepts sorry the X boundaries that
fit in this green bordered shape here
now that seven is immaterial to that all
I need is an x equals zero to know that
I start from zero and I go up to three I
mean you've got eight minus two the X
with respect to X it's worth noting you
could also a phrase this as an integral
with respect to Y but there's not really
much of a point doing that because this
is a function we do know how to
integrate okay now I'm going to go to my
primitive now the eight just integrates
up into an X now this two to the X you
have to be careful right when we were
differentiating things like two to the X
so Exponential's with bases are the than
e one of the results that we proved was
that it would be equal to this if it was
two to the X you get two to the x log
two as your derivative so you're
multiplying by log of whatever the base
number is in this case too okay now
being that we're integrating not
differentiating instead of multiplying
by log 2 I am going to divide by log 2
and that's going to give me the whole
primitive
now we evaluated from nought to three
and off we go so let's see here
well do three first night yes so I'm
getting top boundary 8 times 3 is 24
and then I've got 2 cubed on log 2
there's the top boundary then I'm going
to subtract the bottom boundary so let's
see here
8 lots of 0 is 0 and then I've got two
lots through the power of 0 all over log
2 like I had before
ok let's start to simplify and watch out
for your brackets and negatives and
double negatives especially so up the
front there 24 minus 8 on log 2 I'm
subtracting 0 so that has their impact
then I've got a watch for it a double
negative in here so therefore I'm
getting plus 1 over log 2 two fractions
common denominator sangga get 24 take
away 7 on long 2 and this is an area so
therefore I'm going to conclude without
approximating by saying therefore the
area is 24 take away this square units
happy times ok